Speaker 1: Kerry Lake spoke at a Log Cabin
Republican event and she said she prefers
gay men to straight men. Yeah, it's all bizarre.
It's all very, very strange. Log Cabin Republicans
is a group of gay Republicans. It's we've
talked about them before. Here is Kerry Lake
speaking there. And she is going to explain
to us why she prefers gay men. Very strange.
Speaker 3: I'm innocent. And
so I walked away from all that.
And one of the things that I think some of you
how many of you are intermediate in some way,
shape or form? Raise your hand.
A few of you. This is no secret.
Unidentified: 83% of women in the media are
gay. Okay. And so all of my friends that I in.
Speaker 1: That you guys know that 80, 90, 100%
of the men in media are gay. I did not know that.
I have to admit, after.
Speaker 3: 30
years with those amazing, fun, smart, savvy
people in the world of gay men. And the one thing
I really was going to miss when I walked away
from the media was my neighbors. Right. Turns out
they get into politics. I
had no idea conservative.
Unidentified: Politics is okay when? 91.
I like them better because
they think they know that.
Speaker 3: I think lie.
Speaker 1: Exactly. And I think the gay men
who are, I guess, on the right know how
to think. Right. Whereas the straight men
don't. So this is pretty wacky, but it's an
opportunity to just kind of revisit. Why are
there Log Cabin Republicans in the sense that
the Republican Party has been varying from
implicitly to completely, overtly and violently
hostile to the LGBT community? Why would there be
gay Republicans? And of course, the answers
are not unique to gay folks. Sometimes it's
political values, right? You could have gay
Republicans that support the Republican Party
because they really align with the party
on other values, limited government,
when that's what the Republican Party stood for.
It doesn't under MAGA individual freedom when it
was what the party stood for. It doesn't under
MAGA being strong on national defense. Trump
didn't understand anything about national defense,
so it could just be that they say, Well, I'm at a
disagreement with the party on LGBT issues, but
I'm really in agreement on these other things,
and that's more important. And then you get some
Log Cabin Republicans personal beliefs. You could
have gay Republicans that support the party
because they actually believe in the principles
that the party represents aside from LGBT. And
there are also I mean, I hate to bring up Milo
Yiannopoulos, but Milo Milo Yiannopoulos, who
used to be gay, now he says he's not. It's very
complicated. When he was gay, he said, I'm still
a Republican because being gay is bad. I'm gay,
but I wish I wasn't is sort of what Milo used
to say. And it would be better not to be. So
I'm still a Republican. It was kind of weird and
then strategic voting to some degree. I mean,
if you're a wealthy gay Republican and you find
the Republican position on LGBT issues disgusting,
but you're going to save a boatload on taxes under
Republicans, you might just say, I'm still going
to vote for Republicans. And I just disagree about
this other stuff, but it's saving me a whole bunch
of money so that that's another possibility. Cory
Lake, really strange. I guess she likes gay men
better than straight men. And she also had one
other really wacky thing she said at this event,